[Applaus]
[Musik]
die ukraine ist im zimmer namens europa
der sprichwörtliche elefant denkt mal
drüber lacht europa ist zurzeit das
friedlichste kontinent auf diesem
planeten leben mit ausnahme der ukraine
der in dieses land erst vor sieben
jahren von russland überfallen worden
und die große frage und die sich drücken
wollen lautet was zum teufel tut die
nato dagegen in früheren visual politik
videos haben wir die bereits erzählte
warum die urteile das erste land europas
ist und ja der hauptgrund dieses ganzen
elends ist die korruption der
ukrainischen eliten selbst es ist jedoch
unbestreitbar dass die russische
invasion es der kleine sehr schwer macht
den teufelskreis der armut zu entkommen
dürfen einen blick auf diese karte
[Musik]
seit 2010 fährt die halbinsel krim
direkt von russland kontrolliert
zusätzlich werden die beiden östlichen
regionen donetsk und lorenz von
separatisten beherrscht die wiederum von
russland unterstützt werden
jeden moment könnte russland versuchen
weitere regionen zu erobern
die frage ist also würdest du ein büro
oder eine fabrik in der ukraine eröffnen
wenn du an dem standort jeden moment mit
krieg rechnen müsstest und du wirst
vielleicht sagen komm schon mal glaubst
du wirklich dass russland eine weitere
regionen der ukraine einmarschieren
könnte ja die antwort darauf lautet
warum sollten sie das nicht tun sie es
doch mal so
der krieg zwischen der ukraine und
russland ist völlig unausgewogen ukraine
gibt etwa 5,2 milliarden us dollar pro
jahr für ihre streitkräfte aus und
russland also 65 milliarden euro nach
richten wie diese so besorgniserregend
sind die ukraine sagt dass russland
immer noch 100.000 soldaten in der nähe
ihrer grenzen hält vorerst hat russland
seine stellungen nicht vorangetrieben
zumindest nicht 2014 aber wenn sie es
eines tages tun würden was könnte die
ukraine dagegen unternehmen wie könnte
sie sich verteidigen wie du dir
vorstellen kannst ist die situation in
diesem land kritisch und das erklärt
warum sich die ukraine nach nichts mehr
sehen als nach den folgenden traum
die ukraine über den beitritt zur nato
beschleunigen um ein echtes signal an
russland aussenden
und warum ist das so wichtig wurde der
nato beizutreten nur für den fall dass
einige von euch ist nicht wissen die
nato ist ein verteidigungsbündnis das
heißt wenn ein mitgliedsland angegriffen
wird sind die anderen mitglieder
automatisch verpflichtet ihnen
beizustehen
mit anderen worten wenn die ukraine ein
nato mitgliedsland wäre müssten die
vereinigten staaten deutschland
frankreich spanien die türkei usw
ihre truppen in bewegung setzen um sich
zu verteidigen die frage ist also ist es
möglich dass die ukraine der nato
beitritt und ist die nato wirklich
bereit sie aufzunehmen und was noch
wichtiger ist wie bereiten sich die
streitkräfte der ukraine darauf vor sich
auch so gegen russland zu verteidigen
heute werden wir all diese fragen
beantworten aber zuerst wollen wir dazu
einen kurzen blick auf die geschichte
werfen heißt heute und kalaschnikows
angeblich sagt ein bild mehr als 1000
worte deshalb sage ich dass ein kleines
video damit du verstehst wie die
ukrainische armee bis zum krieg vor 2014
operierte was ich dir jetzt zeigen werde
ist ein offizieller rekrutierungs
werbeclip der ukrainischen streitkräfte
ohne scheiß
[Musik]
versucht also irgend ein ukrainischer
teufel ein paar mädels auszureißen in
denen er mit seinen brandneuen bmw herum
pross etwas ganz normales in der ukraine
doch plötzlich passiert etwas unerwartet
ist ein großer fahrzeug taucht auf
in der ukraine scheinbar auch vollkommen
normal diesen patzer fahrzeug sitzen
drei soldaten die so stark geschminkt
sind dass sie aussehen wie barbies
freund einer steigt aus und die mädels
natürlich sofort total hingerissen vom
schneidigen soldaten der bmw macho hat
keine chance mehr
die message des die jungs wenn ihr schon
mit einem teuren fahrbaren untersatz
angeben wollte ukrainische schnitten
abzuschleppen dann ist so ein panzer
einfach viel besser geeignet als ein
läppischer bmw den würde das nicht
motivieren sich als kugelfang dem russen
entgegen zu werfen das ist echt keine
satire in jeden anderen lang appelliert
die armee in ihrer werbung an
patriotismus verantwortungsgefühl
aufopferungsvollen militärisches
pflichtgefühl oder allerhöchstens
kameradschaftsgeist aber die ukraine
wollen dass ihre jungen männer sich zum
wehrdienst melden um besser mädels
abzuschleppen und dann die ganze nacht
party machen zu können
vergiss nicht dass diese werbeclips echt
sind vor der ukrainischen regierung in
auftrag gegeben und abgesegnet irgend
ein werbefoto musste ich bei ihrer
planung echt gedanken gemacht haben die
haben vielleicht waren diese gedanken
gar nicht mal so abwegig denn im grunde
entspricht dies alles nur den eindruck
den die ukraine damals von ihrer eigenen
armee hatten
ok weiter mit der werbung der soldat
flirtet weiter mit den mädels ja arbeit
in der armee und ich möchte dich
heiraten
dass du ein star und dann fahren die
soldaten davon rheinische armee warum
sollte man sich zwischen krieg und liebe
entscheiden müssen und man beides haben
kann
nun gut nachdem wir uns an diesem
meisterwerk der wärme kunst belustigen
konnten muss ich dich leider wieder in
die harte realität zurückholen
ich lade dir jetzt ein paar zahlen
nennen und die werden dich eher
erschaudern lassen
die ukraine ist einer der größten
waffenexporteure der welt früher aber
den trend 3
die prozente rüstungsproduktion lesen
verantwortlich in dem mehr als 750
ukrainischen waffenfabriken arbeiteten
mehr als eine million menschen und du
wirst dich fragen was passierte mit
alldem nach dem untergang der
sowjetunion nun etwas was umso
schrecklicher klingt je länger man
darüber nachdenkt was das gesamte
sowjetische waffenarsenal ist
verschwunden
das ist richtig es wird geschätzt dass
in der kreide zwischen 1992 und 98
rüstungsgüter im wert von mehr als 32
milliarden dollar einfach so abhanden
gekommen sind sozusagen von laster
gefallen schon sehr sehr sehr vielen
lastern und wo sind denn all diese
waffen wieder aufgetaucht nun ganz
einfach auf unzähligen
kriegsschauplätzen überall auf der welt
von sierra leone bis ex jugoslawien
es war nichts geringeres als das goldene
zeitalter für illegale waffen händler
und zur gleichen zeit für millionen und
abermillionen von menschen ein verdammt
blutiges zeitalter viele brutale kriege
wären ohne die super billigen und frei
verfügbaren explodiert waffen in ihrem
regal ausmaß gar nicht möglich gewesen
gelegenheit macht eben auch kriege aber
die geschichte ist damit noch lange
nicht zu ende
neben den waffenhändlern machte der
ukrainische staat auch riesige geschäfte
mit rüstungsgütern all die ehemaligen
sowjet fabriken produziert immer noch
und was produzieren sie genau nun
hauptsächlich komponenten für russische
waffen systeme zum beispiel waren die
meisten motoren die in russischen
hubschrauber verwendet wurden mit der
aufschrift mediokren versehen um die
reine vorstellung zu geben 2012 war die
ukraine der viertgrößte was ein
exporteur der welt die rüstungsindustrie
ein gigantischer wirtschaftsfaktor an
dem millionen von arbeitsplätzen hin und
ihre hauptkunden waren pakistan china
und natürlich russland und genau dies
war der hauptgrund warum bis 2014 die
mehrheit der ukrainer nein zum
nato-beitritt gesagt habt der ukraine
sagt nein zur nato
es ist nicht überraschend dass etwa die
hälfte der ukraine eine mitgliedschaft
in der nato als ungünstig einstuft und
ja ich weiß schon was du jetzt einwenden
willst also wenn die ukraine so eine
militärmacht ist wie war es dann möglich
dass russland es wagt dort
einzumarschieren nun es gibt zwei sehr
wichtige tatsachen die die in diesem
zusammenhang verstehen müssen erstens
war die ukraine hauptsächlich
auf die produktions und teilen also
komponenten für die weitere herstellung
fertiger waffen spezialisiert mit
anderen worten die ukraine war kaum in
der lage eine bestimmte waffe
eigenständig in einsatz bega form zu
produzieren zweitens war die ukraine
schon damals von jener schrecklichen
krankheit befallen ohne welche sie heute
wohl ein reiches und prosperierendes
land wäre korruption und wenn du dir
vorstellen kannst kannst diese alles
andere als einen weiten bogen um die
ukrainischen rüstungsindustrie gemacht
um dir mal eine vorstellung zu geben
2010 wurden alle rüstungsunternehmen der
ukraine unter einem großen konglomerat
verein to borrow dieses unternehmen
beschäftigt mehr als 80.000 menschen
allerdings haben es diese in zehn jahren
kaum geschafft einen einzigen panzer
komplett herzustellen wie in diesem land
üblich dann hätte fast das gesamte geld
für rüstungsausgaben in den taschen von
action und politikern und was war mit
der armee nun traurigerweise war der
peinliche werde es gibt von verhängen
durchaus repräsentativ würde ihre moral
und kompetenz im jahr 2014 und die
ukraine über 100 68.000 soldaten die
landstreitkräfte zum beispiel über
41.000 soldaten von denen allerdings nur
ganze 6000 griffbereit haben und mit
kauf bereit meine ich dass sie überhaupt
ordentlich ausgebildet und ausgerüstet
waren um eine armee wieder russischen
irgendwie entgegentreten zu können das
heißt nur 6000 soldaten hatten so
grundlegende dinge wie stiefel
tarnanzüge und gewähre
angesichts dieser situation wirst du
verstehen warum die invasion für die
russen ein militärisches kinderspiel und
die frage die wir jetzt mal stellte sich
die ukraine heute verteidigen hat sich
in der zwischenzeit irgendetwas geändert
oder werden sie sich früher oder später
den russen einfach ergeben genau das
werden wir uns jetzt mal aus der nähe
anschauen
eine crowd funding armee nur für den
fall dass jemand von euch in dieser
geschichte den roten faden verloren
hatte
2003 zehntausende ukrainern auf die
straße und stürzten die damals pro
russische regierung im jahr 2014 bekannt
in keine regierung die anti russisch
eingestellt war
dies provozierte die russische regierung
der ukraine dazu sich vom rest des
landes abspalten zu wollen
russland marschierte daraufhin
aufzuhalten ist grimm ein und
unterstützte die separatistischen
rebellen in der region dombach ich weiß
dass das eine sehr grobe zusammenfassung
ist aber wenn du mehr details haben
möchtest haben wir mehrere videos in
denen wir diesen konflikt aus
verschiedenen blickwinkeln betrachten
ich habe sie für dich in der
beschreibung zu diesem video verlinkt
also wie ich denke hatte die ukraine
kaum soldaten die auch in der lage
gewesen wären glücklich an der freud zu
kämpfen aber tausende von zivilisten
zogen aus eigenem antrieb in den krieg
[Musik]
das ist richtig gewöhnlichen bürger ohne
ausbildung ohne waffen ohne jegliche
ausrüstung stiegen in ihre autos und
fuhren an die front zu kämpfen so wurden
die freiwilligen parteiliche wurde
geboren innerhalb dieser batterien gab
es menschen aller art und ideologien
falls du die russischen propaganda
kanäle verfolgst du bereits dass viele
von ihnen neonazi gruppen waren aber das
war nur ein kleiner ausschnitt aus einem
unglaublich bunten spektrum in dem zum
beispiel auch moslem gruppen platz
fanden
okay ist wenig wahrscheinlich
moslems in der ukraine ja die gab es zb
das sheikh mansour bataillonen das aus
tschetschenien kam um die ukraine zu
unterstützen
und woher kann die waffe vor du hättest
dich freiwillig gemeldet und ein
vaterland die ukraine zu verteidigen wie
kommst du an ein gewehr wer bezahlt ist
nun schon mal hier crowdfunding eines
krieges in einem david gegen goliath
ähnlichen kampf setzen die ukrainischen
streitkräfte auf private unternehmen und
crowdfunding freiwilligenorganisationen
um verteidigung software und drohen
hardware im kampf gegen russland zu
entwickeln das ist richtig
konfrontiert mit dem vakuum das die
offizielle arme hinterließ organisierten
sich die ukraine auf ihre eigene art und
weise
so entstanden in die aus wie comeback
live die kur sichere westen und nicht
sich geräte für freiwillige besorgten
[Musik]
allein diese eine ngo gesammelte in den
ersten 45 tagen ihres bestehens mehr als
100.000 dollar ein
aber woher hatten sie so viel geld in
einem so armen land wie der ukraine
die antwort lautet aus der ukrainischen
diaspora
[Musik]
mit mehr als 20 millionen kleiner die
über die ganze welt verstreut sind etwa
365.000 von ihnen leben in den
vereinigten staaten und haben genug geld
um zu spenden so sammelten die
freiwilligenarmee in kürzester zeit
millionen von dollar und gewehre stiefel
und alle arten von militärischer
ausrüstung zu kaufen und du wirst sagen
was für eine rührende geschichte eine
armee die vom volk aufgebaut wurde
aber eigentlich gibt es einen anderen
hässlicheren namen für diese praxis
gesprächen eigentlich von illegalem
waffenhandel und das erklärt nachrichten
wie diese paypal funktioniert und der
gerade nicht aber für einheimische
wissen wenn die man ist trotzdem
benutzen kann aber wir reden hier nicht
über paypal eine der bedingungen die die
usa für die lieferung von waffen an die
ukraine gestellt haben war dass all
diese freiwilligen gruppen der regulären
armee beitreten würden tatsächlich waren
2009 10 fast alle dieser freiwilligen
bereits reguläre soldaten
und hier kommt endlich die gute
nachricht denn diese freiwilligen kräfte
sind sie motivierter und schwerer zu
kopieren weil das du nicht daran dass
die ukraine im jahr 2014 kaum
kaufberater soldaten hatte nun heute
legen wir über 250.000 soldaten
die sind zwar nicht ob das wird aber
zumindest da fügen sie alle über
ordentliche stiefel ungefähre die armee
der ukraine hat sich von grund auf
verändert aber am besten machst du dir
selbst ein bild davon
schau dir mal die neue kampagne zur
anwerbung junger soldaten an
das trio
[Musik]
gut bleibt also noch die frage offen ob
das alles dennoch ausreicht um die
ukraine gegen einen russischen angriff
zu verteidigen oder ob die hilfe der
nato
doch notwendig wäre nun das werden wir
uns jetzt mal ganz schnell anschauen
könnte die ukraine der nato beitreten
die schnelle antwort auf diese frage
lautet nein ich meine niemand an die
zukunft vorhersagen auch jeweils zur
politik verfügten und weil keine
kristallkugel
zurzeit ist jedoch sehr schwer
vorstellbar da ist die ukraine der nato
beitritt und zwar aus einem ganz
einfachen grund wird die ukraine nato
beitreten würde würde russlands größter
widersacher direkt bis an seine grenzen
heran rücken und das wäre eine gewaltige
provokation des in den letzten jahren
mächtig aufgebläht und wird ins
herrschaft extrem wichtigen russischen
nationalstolz ist und das alleine wäre
grund genug für russland bereits im
vorfeld in einen offenen krieg zu ziehen
allein um diese schmach zu verhindern
mit anderen worten das risiko wäre
einfach zu hoch und so traurig ist auch
so die ukraine die sich dieses video
ansehen klingen mag der mögliche gewinn
würde bei weitem nicht das risiko
überwiegen
diese denkweise hat die haltung der usa
und der eu in den letzten jahren
maßgeblich bestimmt aber nicht verzagen
das heißt nicht dass niemand bereit wäre
etwas zur verteidigung der ukraine zu
tun
sie wollen dazu halt nur einen anderen
weg beschreitet seit 2014 haben die
vereinigten staaten über zweieinhalb
milliarden dollar an militärhilfe für
die ukraine ausgegeben das macht nach
viel geld klingen aber ist in
wirklichkeit ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein wenn man erst mit den mehr als 6,4
billionen dollar vergleicht die für
kriege im nahen osten ausgegeben wurden
aber auf jeden fall wartet das budget
ausreichend für die bestückung eines
waffenarsenals mit dem größere verluste
vermieden werden konnten zum beispiel
verfügt jetzt über mehr als 300 humvees
und moderne panzer und artillerie
aufklärungs radarsysteme und alleine
dieser ausrüstung konnte die ukraine
ihre verluste um schätzungsweise 70
prozent verringern
[Musik]
die nato hat auch tausende von
ausbildern geschickt um ukrainische
soldaten zu trainieren
aber du bist natürlich einwenden das ist
alles hätten sie nicht auch ein paar
artilleriebeschuss und sturmgewehre
schicken können schließlich sind sowohl
radarsysteme als auch humvees muss los
um zum anderen überzugehen und verlorene
gebiete zurückzuerobern
wir reden jeder von einem beinharten
krieg wo bleiben also die tödlichen
waffen und hier kommen wir wieder auf
das zurück was ich vorhin erwähnt habe
die nato-angriffe um jeden preis
vermeiden dass sie lässt ist die
situation zu stabilisieren aber nicht
eskalieren zu lassen
das kannst du sehr gut an folgendem
beispiel erkennen wo kleine held
us-militärhilfe darunter javelin
panzerabwehrraketen hast du jemals call
of duty gespielt wenn ja bist du
wahrscheinlich mit dem tragbaren
tabellen raketenwerfer system vertraut
man packt diese panzerfaust einfach auf
die schulter und kann dann selbst lenken
ein projektil abfeuern welche panzer
sehr zuverlässig und präzise zerstören
können das ist eine tödliche waffe und
es ist nicht irgendeine waffe um die
eines vorschlags zu geben jede dieser
einheiten gekostet 280.000 dollar plus
174.000 für jede rakete jeder schuss aus
den rebellen kostet also soviel die eine
ganze eigentumswohnung in fast jeder
stadt dieser welt wie du dir vorstellen
kannst während dieses super
raketenwerfer ein entscheidender faktor
in jeder schlacht gegen russische post
aber es gibt da einen kleinen haken die
ukraine kann ihre 37 brandneue willens
gar nicht dass und einsetzen
ihr habt richtig gehört sie sind
gezwungen sie in einem depot in den
westlichen regionen des landes zu lagern
hunderte von kilometern entfernt vom
kriegsgebiet
und warum so magst du dich fragen
sollten die usa waffen in ein land
schicken und ihn deshalb bieten sie zu
benutzen nun die antwort lautet
abschreckung wieder die vereinigten
staaten noch die natur wollen dass die
ukraine russland an greift sie wollen
auch nicht putins zorn becken also
beschränkten sie sich darauf die ukraine
mit genügend waffen zu
verteidigungszwecken auszustatten und
russland von einer eskalation des
krieges abzuhalten
da diese für putin dann einfach zu
riskant so kostspielig und zu
verlustreich wäre auf diese weise muss
sich die nato nicht über eine
komplizierte und riskante integration
der ukraine als vollmitglieder nato den
kopf zerbrechen und putin wird in seine
schranken gewiesen
dann in politisch jedoch trotzdem sein
gesicht wahren
[Musik]
jetzt ist die frage an sich gerichtet
denkst du dass dies ausreichen wird
werden wir irgendwann doch erneut
russische übergriffe befürchten müssen
ist nur eine frage der zeit bis die nato
voll in diesem konflikt eingreifen muss
glaubst du dass die ukraine ihr militär
wirklich modernisieren kann oder wird es
unmöglich sein die korruption
auszumerzen
teilt eure meinung bitte wie immer mit
uns sondern mit allen anderen ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat was
ja gibt uns bitte ein like teilt es mit
euren freunden und vergesst nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren
was gut und bis bald
[Musik]